[MUSIC PLAYING]
GRACE MOLLISON: I'm Grace.
I'm a Solutions Architect
with the Cloud Platform team.
And I'm here to talk
to you about DR.
So why are we talking about DR?
Well, if you're responsible
for the availability
of your systems,
then you've probably
had a conversation
something like this.
How many of you have
lived that picture?
Yeah, quite a few of you.
So I'm now going
to kind of delve
into some of the patterns and
things that you can do here.
So you'd be aware that whenever
you start talking about DR,
there are some Three-Letter
Acronyms, or TLAs,
where you usually start.
I'd like to start
off by distinguishing
between DR and HA.
Think of HA as being
for micro-disasters.
A single server dies.
A disk fails.
Whereas DR is for
a larger disaster.
A huge chunk of your
production systems break down
and you need to failover
to a different location.
Natural disasters
also fall under there.
So there is a relationship
between the two.
And in some cases, particularly
when running your production
workloads on GCP,
you will see how
HA influences your DR strategy.
For example, using GCP's
global load balancer
means that if a region
becomes unavailable,
your application just
keeps on working.
When we talk about DR,
there are two main terms
that you need to understand.
First there is Recovery
Time Objective, RTO,
which is directly related
to how long it takes to get
your application back online.
It is determined by
what strategy you adopt.
This value is usually defined as
part of a larger service level
agreement.
Secondly, there's Recovery
Point Objective, RPO,
which relates to the
amount of data at risk.
Ultimately, it boils
down to how much data can
you actually afford to lose?
Think of it as the last
backup or checkpoint
you can roll back to.
This metric will vary based
on the ways the data is used.
For example, frequently
modified user data
could have an RPO of
just a few minutes,
as you probably
have the transaction
logs that you can roll back to.
Whereas infrequently
modified data
may have an RPO of several hours
if you need to restore maybe
last night's backup.
Note that this metric
describes the length
of time, not the amount
or quality of the data.
So taken together, these metrics
have a roughly asymptotic
impact on your
bottom line, which
means that the smaller
your RTO and RPO
value, the more your
application will cost to run.
SLA and SLO are
normally conflated,
but the key here is that the
SLA is the entire agreement
and specifies what
service is to be provided,
and how it's supported--
times, locations,
cost performance, penalties,
and responsibilities
of the parties involved.
Whereas SLO are specific
measurable characteristics
of the SLA, such as
availability, throughput,
frequency, or quality.
An SLA may contain many SLOs.
We'll keep those
definitions in mind
as we look at some of the
patterns and implementation
details for the scenarios.
Before we explore the
approaches you could take,
let's take a quick look
at some of the products
and key features
that the GCP has
available to help you implement
your DR strategy no matter
where your production
workload is.
So it's a little
bit of an eye chart.
Cloud Storage.
This is an object store, great
for storage of backup files.
Cloud Load Balancing provides a
single, globally accessible IP
address to front your
backend instances.
It's global, so your
application could
have instances running
in Europe and the US,
and your end users would
be directed to the closest
set of resources.
GCE instances and images,
the workhorse of the cloud.
These are virtual
machines which you
can take incremental
backups of, or snapshots of,
that you can copy
across regions.
You can create custom images
with your application.
You can then use them to
launch instances from.
Managed instance groups work
in conjunction with GLB,
provides a way to
distribute traffic
to multiple copies of
identically configured groups
of instances spread
across multiple zones.
Cloud DNS provides
a programmatic way
to manage your DNS entries.
Deployment Manager allows you
to define your GCP environment
in a set of templates
that you can then
use to create complex
environments, and simple ones
as well, with a single command
repeatedly and consistently.
Equally, you could tear
the environment down
with a single command.
Network connectivity options.
To transfer data
to and from GCP,
you need good connectivity.
So we provide you with choices
in how you can do this.
We have a variety of
connectivity options.
And it's more than
likely that you
will choose cloud
interconnect or direct
pairing to connect through to
GCP for your DR configurations.
So you have a reliable link
and we're not dependent
on the variances of
traversing the internet, where
there is no control on the
hops between your on-premises
and GCP.
I think we're in good shape
now to start exploring
the approaches you can take.
So let's start with looking
at DR when your production
workload is on GCP,
and start seeing how we
can start using this toolbox.
Before I go on, I'm just
wanting to drill into cloud
storage in a bit more detail.
There are a number
of storage classes.
The characteristics
of the specific class
determines the most
appropriate use case.
So in the DR scenario, Nearline
is of particular interest
to us.
Nearline reduces
your storage costs,
but access costs are
higher than standard.
It's designed for
backup-type scenarios
where access is, at
most, once a month.
Ideal for allowing you
to do those DR stress
tests while keeping costs low.
Data is always a good
place to start, I reckon,
so let's look at
data DR techniques
when your data tier is on GCP.
It's safe to assume
that most of you
have databases, perhaps several.
And likely, you've considered
a tiered storage solution.
Looking at tiered
storage in this context,
we are focusing on using
it for backups, where
you have the most recent
backups on faster storage,
and then you archive
off to backups
to cheaper, slower storage.
It's a pretty common pattern.
So Ben's session this
afternoon on building hybrid
cloud tiering with Cloud
Storage for backup and archival
goes into more depth
on this technique.
Here you can see an illustration
of a typical tiered storage
setup on the GCP
where we're using
the characteristics of Cloud
Storage classes to implement.
Inevitably, you'll
need to define
some rules that describe how
objects move between the tiers.
Thankfully, GCP makes
it easy by allowing
you to script a few
simple rules, which
are known as lifecycle rules.
You could do things
like downgrade
the storage class of an object,
older than 10 days, say.
Delete objects created
before March 1, 2017.
Or maybe keep only the
three most recent versions
of an object in a bucket
with versioning enabled.
That's only half
the story, though.
And as on-premises,
you need to think
about what happens when you
need to do a major upgrade
to the database server, say.
If so, then you will
need to figure out
how you can get back to a
version on the database server
that the backups you
stored in Cloud Storage
are compatible with.
It's not as onerous
as it sounds, though.
OK?
You actually have some options
about what you can do here.
We allow you to create
a custom image that
has the relevant version
of the database installed.
Before we go into
that, I want to talk
a little about snapshots.
Snapshots are available
across regions,
which means that if you
snapshot your database,
you can restore it to a
different region as easy
as you can restore it
to the same region.
As you could take regular
snapshots of your system,
this also means each
time you upgrade,
you can roll back
to the snapshot
with the previous
version if you need to.
As a short-term
strategy, snapshots
are useful for fast recovery.
So back to custom images.
When you launch an instance,
you start from an image.
This can be as minimal as
just having the default OS,
or maybe having
been fully baked,
and having your
application, and there'll
be [INAUDIBLE] stored on it.
Decide where on the
continuum your image fits.
Is it fully baked or do
you want just the OS?
When choosing your
baking strategy,
you'll need to consider
things like boot time
and manageability.
Fast boot times are a must
for autoscaling web servers.
But a database server may
not need that fast boot time.
Thinking about how
the instance will
be used in the context
of your DR requirements
will help you determine what
your starting image should
look like.
Up until now, I've discussed
DR techniques applicable
when your database is
deployed on a GCE instance.
However, GCP has a range of
managed data databases that fit
a wide variety of use cases.
So you choose to
use one of these
so you don't have to take
on the operational overhead
of managing them yourselves,
as you do when deploying
a database on GCE instances.
This table lists them together
with some sample backup
methods.
OK.
I've been talking about
data backup and recovery,
but that's only half the story.
You also need to consider the
DR strategy for your application
or service that uses that data.
The techniques I've
already discussed,
like snapshots and the
concept discussed with images,
are all applicable.
We need to bring
your application
and your data recovery
techniques together,
look at the bigger picture
when designing the strategy.
The typical way to do this is
to think about your RTO and RPO
values, and then
what DR pattern you
can adopt to meet those values.
So DR patterns are considered
to be cold, warm, and hot.
Think of these as being how
ready you are to recover
from when something goes wrong.
Think about what you would
do if you had a puncture.
How you deal with it depends
with how prepared you are.
And we could draw an analogy
with the cold, warm, and hot
patterns.
So you're driving along.
You have a puncture.
But you have no spare tire.
So you need to call
someone out to come out
to you with a replacement tire,
and then they have to fit one.
You have to wait
until they arrive.
Moving along the continuum, the
equivalent of a warm pattern
would be if you
the spare or kit.
So yeah, you do have to stop,
but you could fix the tire
or replace it.
And then you're on your journey.
So you've had a bit of a break.
But if you have run-flat tire,
yeah, you need to slow down.
But you don't stop.
There's no real impact
on your journey.
OK?
So it's just basically
the idea of how ready
you are, and therefore, how
quickly you can recover.
So let's look at a
few examples of how
you can apply these patterns
to production workloads on GCP.
This cold pattern
example requires
you only ever have a single
instance up and running.
Here the serving instance is
part of the instance group,
and that group is used as a
backend service for an HTTPS
load balancer.
The heartbeat in
snapshot instance
is part of a managed
instance group.
Managed instance groups are a
group of identical instances
which work with load
balancing services
to distribute network
traffic to all
of the instances in the group.
The managed instance group is
controlled by a GCE autoscaler.
The autoscaler is configured
to keep exactly one
instance running at all times.
If it fails, then another
identically configured instance
is launched in its place.
The heartbeat and snapshot
instance runs a cron job
at regular intervals to
snapshot the serving instance,
and it also checks the health
of the serving instance
at regular intervals.
If the heartbeat and
snapshot instance
detects that the
serving instance has
been unresponsive for a
specified period of time,
it instantiates a new serving
instance using the latest
snapshot, and adds
the new instance
to the managed instance group.
When the new serving
instance comes online,
the HTTPS load balancer
begins directing traffic
to the new instance.
Looking at this
warm static example,
you could see how we're
making use of Cloud Storage
to provide a DR
solution for a web
app running on Compute Engine.
In the unlikely
event that you are
unable to serve your application
from Compute Engine instances,
then you can mitigate
service interruption
by using the Cloud Storage-based
static site on standby.
In the normal
configuration, Cloud DNS
is configured to point at
this primary application,
and the standby static
site sits dormant.
In the event that the
Compute Engine application
is unable to serve
due to a problem,
you would simply
configure Cloud DNS
to point at the static site.
This implementation
of a warm pattern
is one of those patterns
where the cloud has encouraged
you to think differently.
If you do not need
all those wiggly
moving parts all the time, this
could be the pattern for you.
A hot pattern, when your
production's on GCP,
is basically a
well-architected HA deployment.
In this example, we're making
use of a regional managed
instance group together with
load balancing and Cloud SQL.
As I mentioned earlier,
managed insurance groups
are groups of
identical instances
which work with load
balancing services
to distribute network
traffic to all
of the instances in the group.
In this example, we are using
a regional managed instance
group, so we have
instances that are
distributed across three zones.
Now, what's really
cool about regional
managed instance group is
that you get HA in depth.
It provides mechanisms to react
to failures at the application
instance or zone level.
And you don't have
to manually intervene
if any of those
scenarios should occur.
To address
application-level recovery
as part of setting up the
managed instance group.
HTTP health checks
are configured
that monitor and verify that
services are running properly
on the instances in that group.
If a health check determines
that a service has failed
on an instance, the
group automatically
recreates the instance.
Moving up the stack, if
an instance in the group
unexpectedly stops,
crashes, or is deleted,
the managed instance group
automatically recreates
the instance so it can
resume its processing tasks.
And if for some reason a
zone becomes available,
you do not have to intervene,
as by using a regional managed
instant group, there will
still be instances available
serving your application.
The global load
balancer accepts traffic
through a single global
external with IP address,
and then distributes
traffic according
to forwarding rules you define.
You set up health checks here to
ensure that new connections are
only load balanced
to healthy instance
that are up and ready
to receive them.
In the data layer,
we have Cloud SQL,
which is configured for HA.
So we have set up a failover
replica in a different zone
from the master.
All changes made to
the data on the master,
including to user
tables, are replicated
to the failover replica using
semi-asynchronous replication.
If the zone where the master is
located experiences an outage,
Cloud SQL automatically
fails over to the replica,
and your data continues to
be available to clients.
Existing connections to
the instance are closed,
but your application
can reconnect
using the same connection
string or IP address,
as you don't need to update
your application after failover.
After the failover, the
replica becomes the master
and Cloud SQL automatically
creates a new failover replica
in another zone.
This architecture
is a great example
of why, by using services
that provide HA facilities,
your application
can automatically
recover when things go wrong.
My favorite tool in the DR
toolbox is Deployment Manager.
It allows you to define
what your environment should
look like using Jinja
templates in Python.
With a few clicks or a
single gcloud command,
you could bring up an
environment within minutes.
Let's see Deployment
Manager in action,
bringing up the HA web
application we just looked at.
I'd like to welcome Oleg.
Oleg.
One of my colleagues based
out of our Amsterdam office
is going to drive
the demo for us.
Oleg, thanks.
That's Wizard, by the way.
He's our office dog.
And his human.
I did pay him, by the way.
I gave him dog treats for
letting me use his picture.
OK.
So the first thing
Oleg is going to do
is download the set of
Deployment Management templates
from a bucket, and
he's going to deploy
it using the gcloud tool.
Deployment Manager uses a
set of declarative templates
that let you consistently
deploy, update,
and delete resources, such as
GCE, GKE, and Cloud Storage,
for example.
Typically, you have, at
minimum, a configuration file
and one or more template files.
Schema files are also
usually part of the parcel.
They allow you to
declare a set of rules
a configuration file
must meet if it wants
to use a particular template.
The templates, as
I've mentioned,
can be written in Jinja
or Python, your choice.
Jinja is simpler, but less
powerful than using Python.
Using Python gives
you the ability
to programmatically generate
the contents of your templates.
You could pass variables
to your templates,
which make them easy to use.
We set up the Cloud
SQL backend up earlier,
because in reality, you're
not likely to recreate
your database environment
from scratch in a DR scenario,
so we didn't either.
OK?
Bearing in mind, if you don't
have a database ready up
and running, not only would you
need to create the databases,
you don't have to
load it with data.
And it would affect how
long it takes to recover.
And that's what
RTO value you have.
It wouldn't be a small value.
In any DR pattern that involves
a database of some kind,
that tends to be the overarching
recovery process that
dictates the achievable RTO.
So can we look at the
autoscaler template, she says.
So we don't need to
gather around his laptop.
That's good.
OK.
So if you look at
this template file,
you'll see that we've declared
the minimum number of replicas
that the autoscaler can
scale down to is three.
We can switch to--
can you switch to the
GCE console, please?
OLEG: Yes.
GRACE MOLLISON: OK.
So remember, we said three.
So you could see, we've
got three instances there.
Can you delete one
of them now, Oleg?
Go nuts.
So as we have autoscaling
on, it will automatically
replace the instance that
Oleg has just deleted.
I spoke earlier about HA in
depth using managed instance
groups together with autoscaling
of groups being a key tool.
So here we're demonstrating
this capability
at the instance failure level.
But equally, we could set
up a HTTP health check
that we set up
against the group.
In fact, it takes the actual
application one or the instance
failed, it would automatically
create a new instance
and delete the failing one.
OK.
OLEG: We did.
GRACE MOLLISON: Thanks, Oleg.
If you're using a load
balancers as well,
you can also set up
health checks here too.
But load balancer
helps [? tabs ?]
who just stop serving traffic.
They don't actually
remove the instance.
They don't delete them.
OK?
So you need to
understand how to set up
both types of health checks.
The rule of thumb is be more
conservative with setting up
health checks against the
managed instant group.
So as you can see, the
replacement instance
is coming up.
OLEG: Yep, it's up.
GRACE MOLLISON: As
there isn't actually--
we got there in the end.
Sorry about the delay.
As there isn't actually
anything wrong with the zone.
The replacement instance got
launched into the same zone
as the one we were deleting.
So anyone who was paying
attention and notice the zone,
you would see it's
put it straight back
into the same one.
So after that, we could easily
tear down the deployment
by just deleting it.
So, OK.
So this is great if you're
doing test stress of your DR
environment, which
you should do.
So I understand, having
been there myself,
is the fact that doing
full-scale tests are difficult.
This just makes life easier.
You've seen it
[INAUDIBLE] and you've
fired up the environment.
We pulled it down as well.
So you're actually
investing lots of stuff
that staying there that
you don't use very often.
And then you're worried because
you don't use it very often,
why hasn't it come up?
So moving on.
OK.
OLEG: Bye-bye.
GRACE MOLLISON: OK, thank
you very much, Oleg.
Thank you.
Thanks, Oleg.
OK.
So moving on, let's look at DR
where production is on premises
and your recovery site
is Cloud Platform.
So I'll be covering when your
production is just on GSP.
When you're using
GCP as the recovery
site for your
on-premises workload,
there are a few key things
you need to consider.
The initial question
usually being,
how do you connect to GCP?
GCP provides a number of ways
to connect from on premises.
Cloud interconnect
being the ideal way
to provide a consistent,
reliable link.
You need to take into
consideration factors
such as the bandwidth
between you and the carrier
interconnect
provider, as well as
the actual bandwidth provided
by the provider directly to GCP.
Think about what other data
will be used in that link.
Consider how much data
has been transferred
and how long have you got
to meet any RTO values.
You can see from this table--
by the way, which isn't
taking into account
any external factors at all--
that bandwidth
availability does have
a direct effect on the time
it takes to transfer data.
Don't forget to take into
account your security controls.
You may determine that
you want total control
of your encryption
keys, so factor
in the end-to-end
encryption/decryption process.
Who would have access?
Think about authentication
and authorization mechanisms.
How much can you automate?
Remember, everything
is an API, so you
don't need to rely on an
actual, probably sleepy, human
to start bringing up
online your DR site.
I know whenever I had to
instigate a DR scenario,
it was always in the
middle of the night.
I was always half asleep.
So when taking a traditional
approach to DR on premises,
it typically involves,
somewhere in the process, people
driving fans and
swapping tapes around.
The types usually-- or
should I say, hopefully,
being the off-site backup.
Remember-- [INAUDIBLE].
Remember this?
Well, we can use the same
tiered storage approach
to replace the need
for tapes, and fans,
moving tapes on and off site.
We can replace the source to
be your on premises storage
appliance, for example.
So here you need to set
up connectivity to GCP.
So in this example, we're
using GCP's cloud interconnect
service.
You can then implement
a process to copy data
from the storage device
to a Cloud Storage bucket.
This process can be very simple
using, say, the GSU2 command.
You may also want to just
set up a GCS lifecycle rule,
like we described before,
to delete data and move
to a cheaper storage class.
Here's an example
of a cold pattern.
In this example, we have
practically nothing running
in your target GCP project.
When there's a problem that
prevents the production
environment running
production workloads,
you deploy a Deployment
Manager template
to create an environment
capable of running
production workloads.
Note that we were trickling
data into Cloud Storage as part
of that production environment.
You'll need to
implement processes
to restore the applications
to all the instances spun up.
So think back to the
continuum of images
we spoke about earlier.
You'll also need
to think of a way
to transfer data from Cloud
Storage to the database
you spin up in GCP when
you invoke your DR plan,
and start serving production
traffic from your GCP
environment.
This pattern may be the
most cost-effective,
but it has the highest RPO
and RTO values in the patterns
and requires the most
operational effort
to recover from.
Moving on, here's what a warm
standby setup could look like.
Here we have a multi-tiered
application running on premises
while using the minimal
recovery suite on GCP.
Ignore the Cloud SQL
instance for a moment.
I'll come back to that.
You could see that a
database server instance
is running on the GCP side.
The instance must
run at all times
that it can receive replicated
transactions via asynchronous
or semi-asynchronous
replication techniques.
To reduce cost, you
could run the database
on the smallest machine type
capable of running the database
service.
As this would be a
long-running instance,
sustained user
discounts will apply.
When the on-premises
application needs to failover,
you can make the database
system on GCP production
ready by destroying the
small database instance,
making sure to keep the
persistent disk containing
your database system intact.
If your system is
on the boot disk,
you will need to set the
autodelete state on the disk
to false before
destroying the instance.
Create a new instance
using the machine type that
has appropriate resources for
handling the production load
and attach the persistent disk
containing your database system
to the new instance.
In the event of disaster,
the monitoring service
will be triggered to spin up the
web tier and application tier
instances in GCP.
You can then adjust
the Cloud DNS record
to point to the web tier,
which in this example,
points to the external IP
address of the HTTPS load
balancing service.
OK.
So coming back to that
Cloud SQL instance,
if your on-premises
database is MySQL,
you can use the Cloud SQL
replica instead of the VM
instance, and data
will replicate directly
from the external master
to the Cloud SQL replica.
For smaller RTO values, you
could adjust the above strategy
by keeping all of the Compute
Engine instances operational,
but not receiving traffic.
This is not cost-effective,
but may be an option
that meets your needs.
You may want a ready to take
over production workload
database instance,
so you can omit
the resizing of your instance.
In this pattern,
you'll notice that you
have to replicate the
data to your database.
This is one way of ensuring your
DR failover database is kept up
to date.
There are other options for
keeping your recovery database
up to date.
The method you choose
will have a direct impact
on your RPO value.
You may choose to apply
backup and transactional logs
as your data recovery strategy.
This means you do need to make
copies of the transaction log
files, as well as the backups.
You need to regularly restore
backups and apply transaction
log files to your
recovery database,
and test that it acts just
like the production database.
Exactly how you
implement this depends
on the flavor of
database you are using.
Maybe you have a read
copy that can be promoted.
It's similar to the
techniques we discussed
when using HA Cloud SQL.
You could choose to keep
a copy of the raw data
on cloud storage
and rebuild them,
assuming your RTO was
long enough to allow that.
What happens when you've fallen
over to your DR database?
How do you then get
your production database
back up to date?
In many cases, it's
just the reverse process
you'd be following to keep
your DR database up to date.
Data recovery is tricky, and you
need to run regular fire drills
and be totally confident that
you can happily run production,
whether you are using your
production database or your DR
database.
Take advantage of Cloud
Deployment Manager
to spin up your
failover application,
point it at your DR
database to validate.
And once you're done,
you can tear down
your replica
environment until it's
needed for the next fire drill.
If you have very small
RTO and RPO values,
then you could take
that warm pattern
and modify it so it's just
an HA across with GCP, which
gives you a hot pattern,
as both on premises and GCP
are serving production traffic.
The key differences from
the previous pattern
being that everything is
running in production mode
and serving production traffic.
The GCE instances are
part of a managed instance
group behind a load balancer,
and the GCP database instance
is production ready.
If you do choose to implement
this type of hybrid approach,
be sure to consider a DNS
service that supports weighted
routing when routing traffic
to the two production
environments, so that
you are able to deliver
the same application from both.
In the event that one
environment becomes available,
you can then disable the DNS
routing from the unavailable
environment.
So we've discussed
several examples
of using production workloads
in GCP and on premises.
I'm just going to discuss
briefly now what techniques you
could adopt when you're running
production across clouds.
If your application involves
virtual machines running
across different
clouds, again, you
have to figure out
where on the continuum
your images are for both clouds.
You'd want to use tolling
that works across them both.
If it's a fully
configured image required,
consider something
like Packer, which
could create identical machine
images for multiple platforms
from a single
configuration file.
You could use something
like Terraform,
which it's a cloud-neutral
templating tool.
So you might want to--
if you're just running on
GCP, use the native tools.
If you're running
across clouds, you
need to find something that
runs across both of them.
You could use configuration
management tools,
such as Chef, Puppet,
Ansible, SaltStack
to configure your instances.
Or even to configure
the instances
that you'll use to create
the images you'll be using.
That's a very common
technique, and it
keeps everything consistent.
If you need to, you could
set up a VPN between clouds.
If you're using containers--
you know what I'm going to say.
There's only one thing
that needs saying.
It's Kubernetes.
With Kubernetes, you
confederate across clouds.
You can use GKE, which is
Cloud Platform's fully managed
Kubernetes environment.
And then on, say,
Azure or AWS, you
can use Kubernetes on there.
There are other
techniques and solutions
to the ones I've just discussed
that you can implement
for multiple cloud scenarios.
For example, if you want to
replicate data from AWS S3
to Cloud Storage, then you
can do this easily as well,
maybe by using Boto, which
is a Python tool designed
to work with AWS, which also
supports Cloud Storage There's
plenty of ways to do that.
It's not going to be easy.
I'm not going to deny
it, but you can do this.
So just to recap, why using
GCP is the destination
you should be thinking
of for your DR needs.
It improves your TCO.
It's easy to carry
out the fire drill
so you will have a greater
degree of confidence
that in the unfortunate
situation you have a disaster,
then like Wizard
here, your ops team
will be calmly executing
the recovery process.
Also, you don't need to
keep rethinking patterns.
They apply no matter where your
production workload is running.
So there you have it.
If you're thinking of DR, either
to revamp your current solution
or want you to actually
implement a new DR solution,
hopefully we're giving
you plenty of ideas.
[MUSIC PLAYING]